mobilisation contre direction de
l'allemagne mobilisation contre la
guerre et l'invasion russe en ukraine un
rassemblement à la porte de brandebourg
à berlin tout près du tir car ils sont
venus dire non à la guerre et à vladimir
poutine manifestation pour la paix et en
solidarité avec le peuple ukrainien nous
sommes en ligne avec anne maillet notre
correspondante à berlin il y a
visiblement beaucoup de monde quels sont
les slogans
oui effectivement c'est une
manifestation de très grande ampleur à
berlin à l'appel des syndicats de
diverses organisations civiles une
manifestation qui devait réunir environ
1000 personnes les petites annonces bien
plus importante encore puisque les
allennois fui de toute la ville et de sa
banlieue
pour participer à cette manifestation
pour la paix en ukraine et ont réclamé
aussi l'accueil de réfugiés
ils craignent en allemagne un
porte-parole de la police estime
actuellement le nombre de participants à
environ cent mille personnes des
responsables politiques ont également
rejoint le cortège on entend que tu
appelles lignes de métro ont dû être
interrompues car trop de passagers se
sont pressés dans les transports en
commun pour rejoindre le cortège une
tribune a été installé au pied de la
colonne de la victoire en plein coeur de
la ville dans ce parc de tiergarten des
discours sont attendus belle dans
l'après midi
à noter aussi qu'à 15h30 une autre
manifestation se tiendra également
devant l'ambassade de russie à berlin à
l'appel cette fois de citoyens russes
exilés en allemagne pour protester
contre la guerre menée par la russie en
ukraine merci beaucoup à de maya merci à
vous pour toutes vos précisé